[Music]
welcome everybody to law and crime Del
I'm Jesse Weber that 70 show star Danny
Masterson learned his fate in a Southern
California courtroom Thursday after
being convicted of raping two women 30
years to life in prison Masterson did
not speak during the sentencing but
Masterson's two victims did and a
statement from a third woman who made
allegations against Masterson was also
included Masterson was found guilty of
two counts of rape back in may he was
first tried last fall but jurors
couldn't come to an agreement about what
happened in the actor's Hollywood Hills
home between 2001 and 2003 multiple
victims came claim that Masterson
drugged and raped them prosecutors vowed
to bring charges a second time and a
retrial got underway in the spring but
this time around the judge judge allowed
the witnesses to say that they were
drugged despite no forensic evidence of
drugs being presented and the Church of
Scientology featured more heavily in the
retrial it took the jury 7 Days of
deliberations to reach their decision
ision Masterson's accusers are also
suing him and the church in civil court
now during the sentencing the judge had
this to say quote Mr Masterson you are
not the victim here your actions 20
years ago took away another person's
choice and voice your actions 20 years
ago were criminal and that is why you
are here now let me bring in my topnotch
legal analysts co-host Terry Austin
Brian buckmire good to see you here um
so I I don't know who I want to start
with first I'll start with you Terry so
you think about it the victim impact
statements I wonder if that had an
effect cuz sometimes we go into that
saying the judge already knows what the
sentence is going to be however do you
think the victim impact statements
created an impact on it well I do think
they had some impact I do believe this
judge had already made up their minds I
mean here we have someone who got the
book thrown at him 30 years was the
maximum so if you think about it when
you're going to write up a sentence and
you're going to say something you've
already planned that all out you know
it's written you're reading it and and
you've already thought about what you're
going to say one of the things here was
that he did change the lives of these
women and that there's no remorse and
that he's sitting there and he's
thinking probably that the system has
done him wrong and it's also consecutive
right it when explain why that's a you
know a big well I think the issue was
it's different women and so the judge
wanted to make sure that each of them
has their ability to have some sort of
you know consolation here that he is
serving time for their crime that was
committed against them but I I think to
answer your question the judge already
knew but because there was no remorse
and because he sat there thinking that
he had every right to do what he did the
victim impact statements made a
difference Masterson didn't say anything
is that
strategic I think so because it it's 30
years but it's 30 years to life so after
30 years he has possibility to go to
parole board taking ownership for what
you've been convicted icted up was one
of the factors the pro boards really
think about and that could have helped
him got out when he's what 77 years old
and his 9-year-old daughter is then 39
probably something he wants to get out I
think it might be strategic in the sense
of the appeal when we saw that first
trial the majority of the the the juros
were going towards an acqu and then
facts like he pointed out about the
ability to say that they were
intoxicated even though no forens to
back it up and even some of the other
testimony from uncharged Witnesses came
in I think that's a very Elementary uh
appeal just in the sense you can say
no conviction here leaning towards
innocence conviction here look at what
change we want an appeal this was wrong
I think that's why he stayed silent okay
so there might be developments down the
line but right now what a major sentence
for Danny
Masterson and welcome back to Long Prime
daily everybody so the defense team for
alleged killer Brian koberger says that
instead of cross-examining a witness
during a recent hearing Idaho
prosecutors sent the FBI to her house to
do it for them Gabriella Vargas
testified during a hearing of about DNA
testing in genetic genealogy last month
cober's attorneys say that only a few
days later FBI agents came to her door
and interrogated her about her testimony
prosecutor Bill Thompson said that
investigators had heard through some of
vargas's colleagues that she was going
back on some of the things she testified
to in court evidently Vargas may have
signed a written declaration as to what
she was testifying to without fully
reading it police in Moscow Idaho say
that Brian koberger entered a rented
home near the University of Idaho last
November and stabbed four college
students to death Kaye gavz Madison
Mogan zor kodal Ethan shapen they all
died from their wounds now coburger was
a doctoral student nearby Washington
State University Police collected trash
from cober's parents home in
Pennsylvania where he was spending
Christmas break and used a DNA sample to
link him to the sheath of a knife found
in one of the bedrooms here's some of
what Gabriela Vargas had to say about
her involvement in the process during
that August hearing
I
was contacted um by defense um well I
take that back I was contacted by
somebody in this field I don't know if I
could say who it was or if it's relevant
um asking if I would be willing to talk
to the defense um and and I I agreed and
I had that uh it was a zoom call in
which I was asked
um basically just to explain the process
in which I go through from start to
finish on a case so what is you know
from when law enforcement contacts me to
when I provide the investigative lead
back to law enforcement what is the
process and that was the extent of my
involvement at the time in the end what
we provide to what I provide to law
enforcement is is an investigative
lead and it is up to the agency to then
take over their case and confirm that my
lead is in fact correct so let's be
clear Terry the parties they're allowed
to speak to witness right but what makes
this a bit unusual you know I actually
went over the American Bar Association
code to see what the parties can do when
they are investigating and interviewing
Witnesses and both sides can interview
all of the witnesses that they know
about even if it's a witness that will
be called from the opposite team but
here what's very different is the FBI
win and that's a little odd I mean the
prosecution wanted to follow up that
makes sense if there is a change in the
genealogist testimony why not go and
find out what exactly is that change but
usually you send one of the lawyers one
of the paral leals one of the
investigators you don't really send the
FBI so I think that's what's unusual
here I mean you have investigators who
do this for a living who work for the
prosecutorial team or for the defense
team it's just a little odd and it is
intimidating to have the FBI come to her
home and so I think there's a claim here
on the defense side that you know she
was intimidated that maybe she was
trying to change her testimony and the
FBI might have pushed her in that
direction well that's what I was going
to ask you Brian does the defense have
an argument to either the judge or the
jury at a trial about the way this
witness was questioned by the FBI I
don't think they have an argument with
the judge because to Terry's Point while
we may call them the prosecution's
witness or the defense's witness because
they testify on their behalf you don't
actually own a witness I've actually
done this in Trials before prosecutor
says they're about to call someone on a
witness list that I haven't spoken to
before because it's some family member
who saw some random event at a party
that they're going to try to use against
my client I'll slide right into that
room when no one's in there and ask them
a bunch of questions and if a prosecutor
wants to come and knock on there say hey
that's my witness is said I don't see no
your name on this person I can ask
whoever uh I want of any questions but
just as we were all a little skeptical
and it's a little bit unusual we could
present it to the jury and say isn't
this a little weird why would you do
this what if you testified you being the
jury testified one way about something
and then the FBI came to your door how
would you testify then and I think that
is a bit of a seed even though you can't
go all the way and say this a jury
tampering or witness tampering uh but
it's enough of a seat to raise a little
bit of Doubt potential and real quick
they can they can ask that question in
front of the jury about the FBI
questioning her why not okay okay well
that'll be interesting when we have a
trial whenever that happens